hey guys Tiffany Smith year for Fandango
movie clips we've been walking around
the floor here at Star Wars Celebration
in Anaheim and it is awesome I am a
massive Star Wars fan but no fan is
complete without a lightsaber so I am on
the hunt for the perfect lightsaber
let's do this
to complete being a massive Star Wars
man you've got to have a lightsaber so
I'm looking for my first one what are
some tips that you guys have for buying
your first lightsaber make sure the
quality
you can walk it again
like all steel bodies and the blades are
a really tough industrial polycarbonate
so they're pretty much indestructible
this guy here he this one I did a
durability test with this and I shot it
with my 12 gauge
start start graduate okay well how much
one of these set me back it double
curved like this with all the etching is
that although this work your back
working under a little too steep for my
blood the force was not that strong with
me yet we aren't on the hunt for a
lightsaber Oh might have found something
so it's not too expensive I think that
could fit this in my suitcase for
traveling it's a little bit too [ __ ]
for me I think I need something with a
little more size to it next up so the
hunt for the perfect lightsaber is still
on we are you kidding me so what you're
saying is I can't get one of these yet
yes I'm not cool enough I'm gonna ride
he can't catch me
we've been searching for a pretty long
time but I think I might have found some
mother lode we have Darth Maul here red
Anakin blue and then mr. screen.i thinks
that I found my lightsaber and I want to
go with Anakin but I'm here because I
feel like it's gonna be the most
expensive no it's definitely not the
most expensive not the cheapest okay
guys
looks pretty good on me right
okay so my Jedi Star Wars fan training
is now complete because I got my very
first lightsaber oh yeah I went with
Anakin it's pretty awesome I'm so
excited I had such a good time here at
celebration we will be back tomorrow
doing even more awesome stuff here I'm
Tiffany Smith for Fandango movie clips
may the force be with you